my high school friend's dad is friends
with a gynecologist a male gy a male
gynecologist who's in his late 50s and
he's having a party there's like chicks
hanging out you know he's got a gold
chain white hair and I'm like this he's
seen all their [__] yeah what's up
Sharon and I go can I ask you a question
he's like yeah what's up I go so how did
you like how does your mind
differentiate I'm thinking I'm asking
like a very clever question I think for
a
16-year-old like this is a patient
versus this is like a woman with her
legs open and he goes he just flips a
burger and he goes pussy's [__] that's
a doctor and I was
like
okay I was expecting like a of course
some doctor yeah yeah medical
explanation well pussy's
[__] the Honeydew with Ryan